how many days were you on set for dumb
and dumber to unset well I was there for
almost a month in Atlanta but I think I
worked about 12 days out of that so
there was a lot of time to have fun and
enjoy Atlanta to which was just great i
enjoyed it but yeah bout twelve days of
actual actually being on set working and
your character is my character is I'm
not going to tell you his name because
everything that you're seeing now as far
as his name goes and my wife's name goes
and my daughter's name goes is I will
tell you it's a diversion it's not our
real family name and you'll find out why
once the film actually is released why
that name is being withheld okay but
what did you ask me uh oh well let's go
back let's find so you're you're 12 days
in hotlanta what were you doing you know
like to prepare on set I realize it's a
it's a fun city to be in and you were
probably taking in life but what were
you doing to prepare while you're there
are you in a trailer the entire time
rehearsing lines are you watching other
people to kind of get a feel for the
pace of the production I wanted to when
I first got there they took me directly
from the airport to wardrobe and I had
several wardrobe changes during the
course of working on the film so we
wanted to get that all squared away and
then I went back to the hotel and
checked in and I called for Transpo to
see if somebody could take me back out
to the set because I just I wanted to
get I'd never seen Pete and Bobby work I
wanted to get a sense of the tone and
and the pacing of what they were doing
and and to
most importantly meet all the people on
the crew whose job it is to make me look
good those are the first people i want
to make friends with on any set TV film
are the crew i think those are really
important relationships because if you
if you irritate those people they can
very easily make you look very bad too
yeah with lighting that's not quite
right or camera angles that aren't the
most flattering in the world and a lot
of people don't understand or realize
that those relationships are really
really important and yeah so so I wanted
to meet the crew and what a great crew
it was and so yeah that was my first bit
of preparation that i actually did in
town before i worked and and then you
know i had done much of the character
preparation and there wasn't a lot
involved a lot of a lot of my prep
involved specific plot points that i
cannot tell you about at this point but
it wasn't terribly extensive and it was
kind of an easy role to fall into and
once we were actually there on set and
they called action just kind of jumped
in and threw myself into the end of the
maelstrom of activity and with jim
carrey and jeff daniels and the rest of
our amazing cast Rob Riggle and my wife
Laurie Holden from walking dead Rachel
Melvin who played my daughter penny what
and I got to spend a day locked in a
hospital broom closet with Kathleen
Turner and execs simulated sex
in a broom closet it was one of the best
days of my life I she's a thoroughbred
there isn't a better actor out there
than Kathleen Turner I think it was fun
so you just kind of throw yourself into
it and have fun that's all you can do
you